get your dirt sharpened and your bowling
balls ready because we have ten full
episodes of Nazi hunting and I want my
scouts in this video will be breaking
down the absolutely batshit insane
ending as well as that giant twist and
you'll want to stick around till the end
of the video as I'll be going over that
surprise character as well as what it
could mean for season two so grab some
delicious corn syrup because here we go
the last episode begins with the event
that sparked the creation of the hunters
in the first place
Ruth's Idol bomb the grandmother a
protagonist Jonah haidle bomb spots a
Nazi doctor who committed horrendous
crimes during the war she goes to the
authorities but they don't seem to care
at all so she goes to the only person
she can think of to help Meyer Offerman
a wealthy Jewish businessman who she
fell in love with during her time at
Auschwitz
their history is one marred with sadness
their first meeting was during the
liquidation of the ghetto in which he
saved her life as her parents were
shocked it would bring them together
again when it was Meir himself who
tattooed her identification number upon
her arrival to the camp to understand
the ending of hunters one has to
understand the relationship between
these two while at Auschwitz a German
doctor by the name of Ville hems ooks
aka the wolf took a liking to Ruth even
offering her a cushy job as his
assistant with better meals in her own
bed but Ruth was a woman of principle
she wouldn't take it well everyone else
suffered not to mention while her love
Meyer was still out there
the wolf saw Ruth's love for Meyer and
did everything he could to break him in
the middle of the night Meyer is taken
and tortured for nine hours
but even this doesn't break his spirit
it's this event that actually shapes
Meyers philosophy that one must never
hesitate during times of opportunity
while being tortured he could have
grabbed the hammer and killed the wolf
but he didn't do it because of this
since the wolf would go on to kill
hundreds more during his time at
Auschwitz that's why in episode 5 when
Maier confides in Jonah he says to him
let me you not let what's inside to stop
you from doing what
Jonas struggles with making hard choices
throughout the entire season ultimately
going against Meyers wishes by letting
the sadistic neo-nazi Travis live it's
this decision that in Myers mind makes
Jonah no longer a fit to be the eventual
leader of the hunters but she clearly
who and this all connects to Jonah's
character arc episode 1 sets up Jonah is
a scared weak boy he gets picked on by a
local drug dealer is afraid to talk to
girls and witnesses his grandmother
being shot and does nothing who did
nothing to save his grandmother
that's who you are throughout the ten
episodes Jonah grows as a character
trying to prove to those around him that
he's not a boy that he has what it takes
to be a hero and make the difficult
choices heroes must make the boy we see
in Episode one is juxtaposed to the
murderer we see in episode 10 but this
change is the result of ten episodes of
deep inner struggle episode 1 sets up
one of the main ideas of the season what
is good and what is evil when Jonah
leaves Star Wars he tells his friends
that Darth Vader doesn't believe he's a
villain he was just some kid raised and
indoctrinated to believe that the
Republic is the enemy Vader
doesn't get up every day looking to
destroy the galaxy no no he gets up
every morning believing he needs to save
it no villain in their mind sees
themselves as one they believe they're
doing what's right even the Nazis
believe their terrible acts are
justified we're the good guys
Captain Kirk we're trying to save the
world but it's not just the Nazis who
struggle with what it means to be evil
the hunters believe they're doing what
is right but commit murder to do so an
action that separates mire and the
hunters from other groups such as the
one run by Simon Wiesenthal Simon
Wiesenthal is based off the real-life
Nazi hunter responsible for capturing
such high end Nazi officials like Adolf
Eichmann who is found years later living
in Argentina we'll get to Argentina in a
bit Simon argues that by killing these
Nazis you sink to their level if we
follow your path and compromise our
homes what makes us us can be truthful
or educate ourselves this is later
echoed by Detective Morris when she
finds Jonah about to kill Travis you
pull that trigger Jonah and you become
them okay you become the evil you are
fighting this all culminates in Jonah's
biggest decision of his life whether or
not to kill Meyer who as we'll come to
find was the wolf all along while going
through his grandmother's letters Jonah
learns the story of the day Meyer her
true love disappeared more importantly
he learns of the nightmares which
haunted Meyer a recurring dream in which
he brought the wolf out into the forest
and recited a prayer before killing him
now with Jonah bringing the real wolf in
front of him Meyer doesn't say that
prayer in fact he doesn't even let the
sir
speak this combined with the surgeon
saying it's you and some flashbacks like
Myer expertly sewing up Jonah's wound
all culminate in Jonah finding out that
Meyer Offerman has been the wolf all
along there even hints at this
throughout the season such as when Ruth
says to Meyer look different tonight
remember
or when Tilda sour realizes it's him
just before her death and says in German
great pretender clever tongue you see
back in 1945 the wolf having been
captured by the Soviets was sentenced to
death but he escaped killed the real
Meyer Offerman and stole his identity
even going so far as to hire a Nazi
surgeon to make him unrecognizable he
cut off all ties with Ruth as she would
have seen past this disguise in essence
the wolf became a wolf in sheep's
clothing
taking on every aspect of what it means
to be Jewish going to Temple learning
Hebrew and reciting the Torah it was
only by living as a Jew that the wolf
realized the error of his ways you know
I finally woke from the coma of hatred
and I saw the evil a had done to exam
pants and realized that I was the
villain of my own story it would be 30
years later when Ruth showed up on his
doorstep that the wolf was given purpose
in his life she gave me the opportunity
to finally do something that was right
to finally grow a little bit closer to
the light he tells Jonah that the hunt
isn't his redemption it's his penance
the price he pays for his past misdeeds
Jonah then completes his arc killing the
wolf in cold blood leaving us with the
question is Jonah a hero in the moments
prior to killing the wolf the ghost of
his grandmother appears behind him
telling him no she doesn't want him to
go through with it as Jonah become just
like the monsters he's hunted speaking
of potential monsters sister Harriet
ends the season with a big twist of her
own but there's something about this
that just isn't sitting right with me
first we don't really know the identity
of the other person on the phone but we
can assume it's some sort of mentor or
superior to Harriet perhaps one of the
nuns who brought her up as a child but
why then did this person call her by her
Jewish name Rebecca if you remember in
her flashbacks Harriet was punished
by the nuns for using her real name and
eventually she decides to go by her
Christian one Harriet also refers to the
colonel as the queen and they both
lament her death saying long live the
Queen yet neither of them know that the
colonel is still alive in Argentina if
they were on her side you'd think they'd
probably know that or perhaps they just
don't know yet furthermore they have
their own plan which seems to be
separate from whatever the colonel and
her faction are up to this plan includes
bringing Jonah to Europe I'm also
perplexed as to why Harriet would be a
part of a Nazi side anyway she was born
Jewish and it was the Nazis who split
her and her family apart we also know
Harriet used to be part of mi6 and was
brought up Christian in order to keep
her identity secret it's completely
possible that Harriet is playing a
longer con here that she is still a good
guy but is playing the role of a double
agent
having infiltrated a European cell of
Nazis I also want to pay attention to
the use of the phrase
long live the Queen when they're
referring to the colonel if the colonel
was the queen then who is the king this
leads to one of the craziest twists of
the show shortly after the Wolf's death
Joe one of the hunters is kidnapped in
broad daylight and taken to Argentina
there it's revealed that the colonel is
still alive but even crazier so too is
Adolf Hitler Adolf refers to the colonel
as Ava a hint that she is actually Ava
Braun his wife and that these children
here could be his offspring now there
was a tiny hint of this in episode 5
when Biff demands that he speak to the
general the person above the colonel in
this organization this also plays into a
well-known conspiracy theory that Hitler
did escape Nazi Germany and fled to
Argentina along with other high-ranking
Nazi officials what this ending in
Harriet's phone call seemed to suggest
is that this organization is much larger
than it appears to be spanning globally
and infiltrating far deeper than we
could have imagined to make matters more
difficult the hunters have gone from
eight members to four however the ending
teases they'll be back next season to
take on an entirely new gang of Nazis
harriet refers to them as dice pinna the
codename for a covert operation which
saw eight of hitler's highest-ranking
lieutenants fleeing across europe if
season one was all about finding the
Nazis involved in the extermination of
the Jews season two will focus on
Hitler's
and even though everyone's least
favorite Hitler Youth Travis seems to be
locked away it seems he'll be back for
season two at the end of the season he
tells his Jewish lawyer that he needs to
build an army and what better place to
find down and out white people easy to
manipulate and recruit than in prison
expect him to make an escape
then there's detective Morris who was
essentially told to lay off
investigating Operation Paperclip the
operation which saw the American
government give X Nazi war criminals new
identities in America in exchange for
their help in scientific endeavors she's
tasked by a Jewish congresswoman to
start her own Nazi hunting task force so
expect her and the hunters to team up
but also be at odds I can definitely see
these two groups at each other's throats
with the hunters wanting to straight-up
kill the Nazis and detective Morris
wanting to have them tried and sent to
prison finally we have Biff Simpson the
butcher of our love or should we call
him Boris fraud ski and it isn't lost on
us that this frauds new last name is
literally fraud ski he's taken a new
identity in the USSR which is a great
setup for season 2 remember that the
purpose of Operation Paperclip was to
take these Nazi scientists so that the
Soviets couldn't get them yet some of
the Nazis went and joined the Soviets my
guess is that Biff will have some old
friends willing and able to help out
with his new life it's still unconfirmed
whether there will be a season two but
with the introduction of Hitler at the
end I hope it does just to see how
things will play out thanks for watching
the video and make sure to LIKE and
subscribe I have tons of videos on the
horizon you'll want to stay tuned for
you can also follow me on twitter at
think story whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much